Come on. They're going to lecture me about civility,
but you have me on for a pretense, the book,
you don't ask me a single question about the book and you refuse to even mention
my last name. I was like, you know, this is going wrong, real fast.
All right, here.
There we go. This is the Rubin report. I'm still Dave Rubin.
And I have a feeling that YouTube may not be thrilled with this episode.
So even more reason to subscribe and click that bell so that you actually get
notified when the clips come out and joining me today is the VP of the Trump
organization and the author of the new book triggered Donald Trump Jr.
Welcome to the room and report it to be with you, buddy. All right, here we go,
man. I'm,
I'm 50 50 on whether this stream is going to be up by the time I finish this
very sentence right now.
It's sort of a win either way, right? I mean, if they sensor you,
we can blow it up and make it go everywhere. And then other people will watch,
but it's the same that we even have to have that conversation. Right.
Sorta ridiculous. We're going to get to that.
And that actually has a lot to do with what you write about in the book here
about all the tech, censorship and all that stuff. But before we do any of that,
uh, I don't know if you remember,
but a couple of days you were on the view that you program on. No,
one's mentioned that to me since. Yeah. Do you remember that?
So there were so many things that happened in that interview that I was like,
Holy cow, this is everything that I talk about all at once.
So let's just try to hit a couple of things in a row here. So first off,
the way the interview started, where Whoopi, who I used to really like would be,
I think she used to be a decent liberal,
and now she's kind of gone off the progressive deep end.
She couldn't even say your name in the intro.
She literally refused to say your name. What,
what does that feel like when you sit down and you know,
you're in enemy territory and then the way they treat you before anything
happened?
Well, listen, it obviously shows just how disingenuous,
the whole thing is first and foremost, right? I mean,
they invite you on to talk about your book. Did you hear a question?
It'll a little one meeting three segments. I'm not a baby. Right?
Like I get like, I'm going to get hit. I get that in that case, you know,
there's not even a conservative on my side,
given the history and you know, Abby Huntsman sort of what are like,
there's not a lot of personality there for that kind of stuff. So, you know,
I get it, I get that. I'm going into the lion's den, but like, come on,
they're going to lecture me about civility,
but you have me on for a pretense, the book,
you don't ask me a single question about the book and you refuse to even mention
my last name. I was like, you know, this is going wrong real fast. But.
Basically said that the son of the president, then she kind of choked out, uh,
DJT.
Don junior, I think, or Donald junior. She said like, she,
she didn't say she never said Trump. You know, I'm like that. It's okay.
I guess people know, but like, what's the PR what does it serve?
But it does set a certain tone and that's been consistent. I mean,
Ron Paul was on there a couple of weeks ago and the way they were treating him.
But then a few things happened in a row that I thought were pretty interesting.
So you started getting hit and you apparently had done a little research because
you turn the question around and said to joy, you know,
joy you've been in blackface and now joy has been in blackface.
She has admitted it on the view.
She immediately said she hasn't whoopee then said, well,
I'm a black woman and I know a black faces.
And what B and you supported Roman Polanski at a rapist.
So it's not rape rape. That's what she said, you know? Yeah, you're right.
Sodomy of a 13, 14 year old girl, the under Quaalude. You're right.
That's not rape will be like, if that's not rape, I don't know what he is.
And now you're seeing, by the way, like literally the day after, like it broke,
like some other woman accused him of that one rape rape.
Like I just want to make sure we're clear. Uh.
You make of the idea that they never get these things turned on them.
That that's what was so shocking to me. Nobody does it, even though we all know.
Correct. And it was funny. Cause I see that, I mean, in the last couple of days,
just doing these book signings, like even these guys, you know,
we'll come to the books on a little bit. I love what you did on the view.
I'm like, what were you doing? Watching the beat? They're like a ball.
It was sort of funny, turn it around. But you know, I think what it is,
honestly, Dave, so many people are used to going on. Those shows.
They have big viewerships, they have big following.
They want to get invited back, you know, they're there to pitch something.
And as was, I mean, I didn't just go on there for fun. Right. Uh, you know,
they're there to pitch something. So they're,
they're so desperate about wanting to be invited back that even though it was
their five thousands episode, I don't think anyone's ever pushed back on them.
You know, they can sort of say it's, it's the view, not views, right.
There's one view. And if you don't have it, uh, you know,
they're going to go in after you.
And so I guess I just sort of took their script on them and people are like,
well, how much did you prep for again, prep for that? I literally like,
I was like, you know what, let me have something in my back pocket.
If we can have a civil discourse. It's great. If we can talk about it and again,
understanding that it was not your intention to flip it on. Know,
I that's why I sort of held off, but it was like, they went at me so hard.
I figured, you know, Hey, if I'm on for three segments, okay, Hey,
we'll talk a little bit and then they'll get rough. But like, you know,
just the opening salvo is just aggressive.
Even the conservatives sort of come at you. So I was like, okay, like game on.
Like I can play. I mean, so I didn't prep, but I went on Google for,
but I was like stupidest things I've ever said on the view like, Oh wow,
this was, this was not like a well-researched, you know, counter attack measure.
But like, it was like,
it was good to have something in my back pocket that shows a lot about
hypocrisy.
What does that tell you more broadly about the media though,
that they usually know?
They can sort of say whatever they want and I don't mean just the view hosts,
but basically sort of all, all the lefty media can say whatever they want.
You guys just sort of take the hits usually.
And then the media then we'll cover their tracks. After that.
That's sort of the game that I think a lot of this.
People won't even go because most people are afraid of the confrontation on, in,
on a live screen and stuff like that. They're well, you know,
they're concerned like me, the difference between me and so many people,
like I don't care what the media says. I mean, some of the guys that I,
you know, I spend a lot of time with now in politics and stuff. I mean,
they've literally had the reporters call back, like, what is it with dungeon?
He just doesn't seem to mind when we attack. I'm like, I don't like,
it means absolutely nothing. Do you think that's directly from your dad?
I guess it's just listen. I've been used to it. Uh,
I think there's a genetic component. You know, I sort of joke in the book.
I say, you know,
it took us probably 41 years to realize that we were much more like each other
than you would've thought, you know, with my hobbies, the outdoors, the,
this like my, you know, sleeping on couches in the Midwest.
Like that's not his thing. He doesn't understand that.
And so I think if anyone would have asked us prior to sort of
the viciousness of politics, they would have been like, you know,
Dom's the one that probably least likely. And it was like, now it was like, Oh,
well they kind of fight the same way you back us in a corner,
you attack us for three years, mercilessly, we fight. And uh,
you know, I guess that's the difference. It just doesn't bother me that much.
So I don't, I don't really care what other people think of me.
It's never been something that's phased me that much.
And so I'll get my part out and whatever they say, they say, I don't freak out.
If I get a bad press, I get bad press every day. Like they try to, you know,
anything I do and say can be used against me. I had, I mean,
this is relevant because it's literally today,
veteran's day in the book I wrote, uh,
there's a chapter about sort of the victory. And I say, you know,
after two years of sort of that just fighting during the campaign, you know,
when we won on election night, like I was not at all like, excited about it.
It wasn't like, you know, we want a hockey game and it's like yesterday,
two hours of, and it was so vicious. So the,
the ups and downs, the ebbs and flows, they're so intensive. It,
it wears you down and beat you down. So when we won and they're like, we got it,
we I'm pacing around like a caged animal. Be like, no, no, no, they're good.
They're going to do something. They're going to take what Hillary said,
Trump supporters were going to do what they're going to do. Exactly.
That I turned out I was right, right.
Meaning they were going to try to get that they were going to protest in the
streets. They were, that's what she's saying. Trump supporters are going to do.
Right. They're not going to accept the result a hundred percent.
So I was there like, no, no, no.
Like I figured this game out now they're going to do something. So,
so when John Podesta got on stage and was like.
Well, I was like, I was happier about that.
Even though it meant we were still fighting and it wasn't over.
And then I was that we had one,
which is a pretty worked reality. But again.
Was that night. What was that night like though when,
cause Hillary didn't concede that night.
Did you know? She did later on that night. Yeah.
It was sort of a wishy-washy concession. And then it was like,
let's see if we can pull some recounts,
turns out we actually got more votes than the recants. And, but, you know,
so I wasn't at all psych it, it didn't hit me yet. You know,
what we had wanted accomplished.
So I write a chapter in the book saying when it hit me was literally like two
and a half months later. And it was rolling into Arlington. Um,
and you know, for the replaying ceremony. And I was like,
I'm not an overly emotional kind of guy. Like I said,
I can kind of compartmentalize the hate and just move on. But like duty it,
it hit me pretty hard and it,
I were rolling into Arlington and you see the gravity of the responsibility that
is, you know, what my father has to do right now. Like,
and I was so happy then just the,
it all hit me then because he's the guy in charge.
I know he's going to be such a good leader.
I know he's going to get out of these endless Wars and you're seeing it.
And like some guy I'm like, left-wing like try it's takes like some of it,
he compared his sacrifices. Like I said, they had everything,
all the BS that we've been going through a hundred percent worth it.
Cause he's the leader now that we need.
And they tried to make it seem as though, like,
I was obviously saying that my sacrifices as a business,
as a person over a campaign was the same as the death of Americans.
Like I was like, honestly, I can't even engage because they'll try to build,
but like no reasonable person outside of like left wing and like vanity fair.
And these like loser pubs that will try to take like anything you say and dunk
on you.
Like no reasonable human being of the thousands that have reached out to me that
love the book. Not one has even thought men.
What they're saying I must have meant was what I meant.
I don't think any reasonable person was, but that's what they will do.
And that's the sickness, uh, that is really out there in the media.
In a weird way though. Do you guys kind of need that now? Like it's,
you know what I mean? Like it's sort of become this self fulfilling prophecy.
It's like the media is awful.
Everyone watching this knows that they keep doubling down on lies and, and,
and racism and homophobia and all that nonsense.
And we'll, we'll get to talking with you before we ever got into politics.
Right?
Let let's just do that real quick. I was going to save it till later, but,
but about eight years ago you did my Sirius XM show.
It was on the out to gay channel. I didn't want to be on the gay channel,
but they were like, you're gay. We're.
Putting you up separately.
Okay. So I guess I did start somewhere, but, but it was separate but equal.
You know what I mean? You have an equal radio channel, but it's the gay channel.
But anyway, I got in touch with you.
You came on the show and at this time again, eight years ago,
you were for gay marriage. Your dad was not,
this is way before he was running for president or anything.
And I asked you about that and I'm not going to, you can repeat what you said.
Basically.
I probably said something to the effect of, you know, what,
happy people are productive people. It doesn't bother me at all.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.